We've just talked about which display method gets called int present question
method? The method has a parameter whose type is question. So here's the
parameter variable. It contains an object reference which points to an object,
an object of what type, while you think it's question, because that after all
has the type of q, but not so fast, the type of q, the variable isn't the
question. The type of the object is really not known. It could be any sub-type
of question. Now the good thing is, that when the program runs it does the
right thing. At runtime, it's determined what the exact type of this object is.
And its display method is caught. That might be question.display, choice
question display, or the display method of some other class. That also extends
the question class, this is a very useful feature because it allows us to write
generic codes such as present question that works with questions of any type
and actually this diagram should be familiar to you, you've seen the same
diagram when we talked about interfaces and there is the name for the fact that
the correct version of a method Get selected at run time. Remember what that's
called? Was it object already has programming? Incapsulation? Inheritance? Or
Poly morphism?